life is short is so pleased to have bud
light seltzer as our presenting sponsor
listeners know that we're big fans a bud
light seltzer it's a delicious hard
seltzer from bud light but it has no bud
light in it that's right each one is
just 100 calories 5 alcohol by volume
and gluten free the retro summer pack
has been our go-to drink it really has
we've been lucky enough to like spend
some time with family at the lake and
doing all those summer things never far
away is our retro summer pack i mean i
love that summer ice it's so hard to
beat that i know you like the blue
raspberry a relative of ours they went
crazy for the cherry limeade and thought
and thought you're cr how are you not
enjoying this one the most so we've
loved partnering with bud light seltzer
to bring you some of our favorite summer
memories and we've got more in store
later in the show so stay tuned
[Music]
i was recently as listeners may know in
the country of bulgaria one of the
things i loved most about it was how
direct how honest the people were
they were occasionally like disarmingly
honest and i remember in one case
the makeup artist his name was nasco we
shot long hours and occasionally he
would look at me and say um
you look you look very tired
um
and i was and he was always right i did
look tired and
a few times he'd have to fill in my i
had little like wispy facial hair i had
like um i hadn't shaved for a couple
days in the movie and the first day he
did my makeup he started filling it in
he started filling in my face because i
have some sparse patches on my face and
it's a generous way of putting it yeah
quite sparse patchy and when american
makeup artists do it they would say you
know they would like placate me by
saying oh no everyone's got you know i'm
just filling it in a little bit they
would find some way to diminish it and
uh i asked nazca what he was doing he
said well you have very little hair
there so i have to add more you just
don't have enough
well in your defense the the bulgarians
correct me if i'm wrong are quite your
suit people they are so it must have
been extra surprising that a 43 year old
man
still had kind of pubescent facial
pattern facial hair pattern let's talk
more about it okay life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you can't even see our facial hair so i
don't know why we're talking about it at
all but life is short i'm your host
justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my brother
christian that was a little different
intro yeah is that bothering you
changing it up a little bit but who
cares yeah we're gonna spice it up yeah
it's a new i i need a month i need to be
rattled out of my comfort zone yeah you
do you need to be shaken because um
you can get complacent me personally
yeah or one one can yes well i'm i can
get i think you thrive in complacency
you like you're a creature of happiness
in a good way that was a very insulting
thing you just oh you think i think so
you thrive in complacency you're a
creature of habit you're like very good
with routines
and that's much nicer than you thriving
complacency
complaint uh complacency maybe was the
wrong word thrive was the right word you
excel most when you're doing nothing
you are you excel at apathy
um you uh you're one of the most idle
people i've ever known
idly speaking of idol uh you've been
changing and facial hair you've been so
idle and you're cape and you've grown
facial hair that you've been kind of
changing it up a little bit you've been
experimenting is that safe to say with
your facial hair i let myself go a
little bit well that's a that's i think
an unflattering way when it comes to my
facial hair oh not my entire style is it
unflattering that i assume that that's
sure is
thanks a lot no i just love my facial
hair grow a little bit and it got a
little because it's summer and it's you
know sweaty and gross the mustache part
of my facial ear was starting to
irritate me well you asked yeah yeah and
um so i thought it'd be
an interesting experiment i've never
done this to just shave my mustache part
leaving the rest of it grown
and then suddenly i realized what would
happen when i did that it transforms
your totally i looked like an amish
person yeah do you hesitate to say that
because you think it might be insulting
it's not insulting no it's just
happening i look like the um
stereotypical amish person i mean say
what you want about the look of it i
think it's a very practical thing to do
with your facial hair
because when you get rid of your
mustache it frees you up more and you
don't get you know food stuck there or
drinks stuck there it's
if you kiss someone it's
less defensive that's true so it's just
everything that's underneath your mouth
it's just a little hair kissing it's
just harder to get to the kiss it's just
worse in every way it might look more
pleasing if someone's gonna look at you
it's but practically speaking that amish
facial hair luke
is i think a very smart loop see i'm
surprised that you're willing to do it
because you you're somebody that that
your is it your anxiety your ocd
is such that you need things to be
completed you don't like leaving things
incomplete yeah i don't know if that
that would play and so that doesn't
trigger you in anything no because i
think it's i also like experimenting
with different looks yeah it looks very
i gotta say when i saw you with it it
was
jarring yeah i'm sure and um yeah the
first thing that comes to mind is some
sort of amish do how much people listen
to this i hope so i mean can they are
they allow i don't think so but maybe
they like overhear it sometimes they
can't listen to the radio when they're
on their rumps brigham they can listen
oh yeah that's right they'll go crazy
listen to podcasts you know do you
imagine going on rum spring and that's
the first thing you do is just listen to
a bunch it would be a really boring
rumble if you listen to the show yeah um
but macky said i looked like
uh moe's
from the office do you remember that
character oh yeah played by michael
shurer who's one of the great writers uh
on that show
and he played dwight schrute's beat
farmer cousin mose now dwight schrute
was played by
our guest today hey uh the great the
very funny the very talented rain
wilson you don't have to say his name
no but i there's two n's so i like to
pronounce them both rain
like when you meet a greg with two
greggs i like to say them can you think
of a greg
greg um clark gregg
yes he has two g's greg lloyd football
player former football player not greg
olson no i think he has one g we're
we're off top i know i know so okay
brain wilson has two ends in his name
but that's he explains the least
interesting things about yes but he
still does explain it in this upcoming
interview with rayne i was so nice to
catch up with him again i hadn't seen
him in many years um rayne and i did our
first movie together it was galaxy quest
he also has great podcast he does it's
called metaphysical milkshake a great
name uh he is very bright
he is he has some
some things in common with his character
on the office i think it's certainly
intellectually well that's something we
should maybe talk about after the
interview i know i was seeing if you
would
pick up you know i
i don't love changing things up but um i
should change things up more often be
more willing to do that but i don't like
changing it up to that extent no that's
like talking about outro things in the
internet you thrive in complacency
uh go to full circle that's a classic
intro full circle and uh let's get let's
get into it please um speaking of
circles beets are circular and
rain played a bee farmer no all right
let's just get into it why did i need
another segway i had one
ah really guild in the lily the segway
lily here we go curious
oh boy
oh boy please keep all this stuff yeah
well not all of it well no
yeah you know what maybe all of it would
that be funny
okay um we'll keep that in
no
uh here it is my ketchup with my old
galaxy quest co-star
is co-star yeah we were co-stars a
little arrogant it's a
co-supporting player sure the delightful
and very bright rayne wilson
life could be a dream sweetheart
rain do you ever have these issues on uh
metaphysical milkshake no we don't we're
professionals
um
you know listen
being an amateur amateur means for the
love of amateur it's a
latin
and there's nothing wrong with loving
podcasts and just wanting to get in on
the game
you know
i'm a fan
you're a fan and you want to i get it
yeah you want to interview some
celebrities i know how this happens yes
i i want to feel uh liked i i that's
been my life's pursuit
yes i relate believe me yeah it's you
know it's actually not really a joke
there's a lot of truth in that but why
rain why how did this start what was the
impetus for your podcast besides wanted
to be liked
well metaphysical milkshake is a
honestly in in all sincerity it's been a
lifelong passion of mine
i
love
life's biggest questions i've always i
was the kid
who at like
the dungeons and dragons slumber party
at age 13 was like
hey what do you think happens to us
after we die
you know
i literally and at a high school dance
once went up to a girl and said do you
believe in god and she ran she literally
ran away like
ran away from me
where did that come from do you think
was it was that around the family dinner
table were there discussions like that
happening
how did where'd that come yeah
i i had a family i grew up in a family
that was very into
kind of uh philosophical and spiritual
pursuits um
they were members of the baha'i faith
and so we often discussed
a lot of different religious
ideas and spiritual ideas and
philosophical ones and we had lots of
books on our shelves of
ancient egyptian religions and
stoicism and all kinds of stuff and but
so i think that that contributed but i i
think also just me normally i'm an
inquisitive fellow justin
i've always been interested in this
stuff
was the baha'i were they open to i'm
trying to remember because we had pen we
had another you're our second
baha'is baha'i yeah yeah
um and and i remember him saying there
was an inquisit it lent itself to an
inquisitive nature that there wasn't any
there wasn't i grew up catholic and
there was more certainty uh about a
religion like right whereas the baha'i
was more
searching was if anything uh encouraged
um what other member of the baha'i mafia
did you have on your part
pen
pen badgely yes yes yes i know penn very
well um oh yeah so one of the principal
teachings of the baha'i faith is called
the individual investigation of truth
so
baha'is are called upon to always
question and always try and find the
truth for themselves it's kind of grown
into the dna of the religious faith um
and in fact
you know when you grow up a high you're
not it's not assumed you're gonna be a
baha'i that's you that's on you to have
your own journey that's interesting uh
and pick
how did that mentality
manifest itself in your parents
raising of you i mean how did they how
did they encourage your um
[Music]
your that that in you that kind of
searching mindset that's a great
question i guess like for me was
i i mean the best way was by example
like yeah when people would knock on the
door uh
and say like oh we're jehovah's
witnesses or we're mormons or whatever
my parents would invite them inside and
and serve them breakfast and say hey
we'd love to hear about your spiritual
beliefs you know we'd love to hear
and
so
we were often engaging in in those kind
of discussions really
cool
yeah we had people of a lot of different
religious weird buddhists over and sikhs
and
you know people of different backgrounds
and
now don't get me wrong justin it's not
like i'm painting a very beautiful
lovely picture but it was it was a
really screwed up family my
my parents were not very good at
parenting and um they didn't love each
other
so there was there was a lot wrong with
this equation but
yeah but at the same time this was one
of the things that i'm very grateful for
yeah absolutely i bet you take the good
with the bad you take them both and
there you have yeah exactly what was
that and what was the reason for because
i'm i'm interested in this too rain that
you you grew up in washington state but
you lived in nicaragua for a few years
was did that have anything to do with
their dysfunction or or with their faith
some of both like the mosquito coast i'm
imagining the mosquito coast it wasn't
it was literally the mosquito coast oh
wow really we literally lived on the
mosquito coast it was a place and we
lived there yeah so you're on the east
side which for for the few of you who
don't know that that part of nicaragua i
know it's it's uh
no one goes there really i mean even
natives are seldom they're because it's
just filled with malaria right it's just
swamps yes it's just absolute mangrove
swamps and wow um
yeah they moved there when i was about
three years old
um
and it it it was part behind and it was
part dysfunction my
dad had just gotten a divorce from my
birth mother and she had left him for a
theater director in seattle and it was
all this kind of like
michigas and so he's like i'm taking the
three-year-old and i'm going
down to nicaragua and i'm going to go be
a baha'i
down with the
native mosquito indians on the coast of
nicaragua that's 19 right 69 yeah oh my
god so talk about free thinker i mean
what uh that that's that's beyond
bohemian that's like there's four people
who have done that that's crazy
yeah and he his his business was he had
two businesses
he ran an oyster farm and he did a
classical music
radio show on the local bluefields
nicaragua radio station
oh my god
that he was what type of show you have
classical music so he had he brought all
his albums down from the states i don't
know how he did that
just before like ups you know
and
so he had
you know he had a hundred classical
music albums and he would take them out
and he'd be like here's an aria from
donozzetti's
tosca
you know
act three
song number four i don't know how to do
it and then and there would be all these
you know mosquito indians and there were
a lot of like cowboys and creole folk um
the east coast of nicaragua is
one of the most diverse places on the
planet they speak english pigeon english
creole uh spanish and mosquito
um
and some french because there's like
some haitians were there and stuff like
that and it's it's just kind of the wild
west out there it's it's crazy well rain
what when did you how long were you
there then what was your life like there
in nicaragua well i was there about two
two and a half years
and i don't remember a ton about it
because i was
i came back i flew home when i was five
years old
so
i have you know like in those child
memories that you have like i remember
you know i remember that we had a pet
sloth
[Music]
yeah
oh my god
sleepy what'd you name the sloth i ha i
don't remember what we named the sloth
but i had a really normal name like tony
or something like
[Laughter]
that's amazing and it just lived up in
the trees no
lived in a cage
and then every night there's an
absolutely true story every night
it would it was very sloths are
incredibly strong
um but incredibly slow obviously hence
the name and every night it would
tear open the bars of its cage
and
crawl out
but it couldn't get very far because
they're so slow
so
in the morning my dad would go out and
look for the sloth and be like he's got
to be within like 30 foot range oh my
god and he would find it
and he would pick up the sloth and he
would put it back in the cage and he'd
bend the bars back it was just
it was like a samuel beckett play you
know
yeah waiting for tony oh that's really
that's really funny i have some crazy
memories one time we went out
because he was it's similar to
missionary work i mean it's not i would
like to think that the baha'is work was
not as hey let's convert the native
dogmatic or no yeah he was definitely
there
sharing the word about the baha'i faith
with the natives and we went out to
these mosquito villages and we would
spend the night and
my dad went on a boar hunt with the
mosquito indians and they caught a boar
for dinner and they brought it back
and they roasted it over a fire and
everyone ate the boar and they gave me a
piece of boar meat
and
i got the piece with the bullet in it
if i had a nickel
um
i remember eat i remember the sensation
of eating it i was like this doesn't
taste good it tastes like metal and it's
like
and i was like what is this and then my
stepmom
she opened it up and saw that i had the
piece with the bullet in it oh my god
but other otherwise i wonder
where they apologize see now i'm
imagining our parents were so different
but i'm just imagining
how they would have it's impossible i
would never be in that situation but um
so what are parents that put you in that
situation which is i think is incredible
well how do they react to that moment
are they apologetic are they oh honey
take that out of your mouth
i don't i don't remember
uh what their reaction was but
i think my stepmom was not really having
it she was not terribly happy down there
and my dad was probably like yeah well
you know it comes with the territory you
know
well no you go you hunt bore with the
mosquito sometimes you get
it's like one of those platitudes listen
right you go and hunt boar sometimes you
get the piece with the bullet in it so
you gotta chew on a bullet or two
i know enough about this part of the
world that it's it is
i keep i keep thinking about malaria and
how how did you avoid yeah that danger
because it's a very real danger there my
dad uh seriously almost died of malaria
uh he he got it really bad and it would
recur
i remember him best spending days in the
bed and they were like you know can i
see my dad like no he's sick and he'd be
shivering and sweating and it was really
bad
god yeah
but we all really had
we had a lot of bad diseases then um but
i i had amoebic dysentery
um
which is no fun
when you're four years old and i also
tell you about it
yeah
please and
i also had um worms
oh my god and
and they were giant they were giant
worms nope and when you when you take
the deworming medication no guess where
the worms go
your butthole yes they come out of your
butt your butthole oh boy oh boy oh boy
did you were they um oh boy you could
feel them but they were long you pulled
them out oh god i don't want to know but
i want to yeah they just started they
just started emerging so you'd be
walking down the street and
and they were like
they were like as white as marshmallows
they were like oh god mint free
giant earthworms
well uh that's all the time we have
thanks everyone life is short
life is short
get it his name is long and the podcast
is life is short do you get it uh oh
wait i just oh yeah
did you put that together
i hadn't i hadn't but wait
but justin we were talking about this
because we were talking about
metaphysical milkshake because
this is
i'm just wired to kind of be thinking
about
large important and sometimes ridiculous
questions it makes sense now that i'm
getting i'm gleaning a little bit about
your upbringing and that you also
witnessed these
very
dire situations you witnessed your
father
you probably had a concept of death then
i mean you're four or five i guess those
are formative years
then how did that translate so you say
when you're in school you were the the
kid which is odd for kids at that age
but um you must have found a group that
you must have found other kids who were
similar who gravitated toward you you
mentioned dungeons and dragons uh were
those the theater kids is that how
did that lead directly into theater well
i kind of floated around the various
pockets of nerdum and
i think it's important to understand
that in the early 80s when this was was
there was nothing cool about being a
nerd there was no there was no
there was no street cred to nerds you
know it wasn't gamers or cool or
before beck was a rock star and it was
you know before steve jobs before galaxy
quest so yeah it was it was the dungeons
and dragons i was on the chess team
so a lot of those guys in that set were
fine talking about those questions
um questions with larger metaphorical
implications and then when i got a
little older i did switch over to the
drama
crew
uh because
i uh found that i could
act ridiculous and make people laugh
occasionally and then
actually cute girls would actually talk
to me
which was uh very different than the
chess club
situation
well rain it's interesting because i
this comes up a lot in my life when
people um
people who i could tell clearly didn't
have those
classic nerd traits i guess in high
school when they
they claim to have been a nerd it
sometimes annoys me do you ever get do
you ever do you have a sense of
propriety over the turn that term now
that it's cool now that you you've uh
we've both
done well playing nerds
[Laughter]
that's true um
yeah i mean sometimes it's like
you know there'll be some like
incredibly uh attractive yeah person
and they're like oh i was a nerd you
know brie larson will be like i was a
nerd in high school so come on
come on give me a break
you know i don't see you in the oboe
section
okay three right yeah
but with a lot of comedy writers too
they they kind of claim the same thing
but you know it was when i was a nerd
that we were outcasts i mean yeah you
got the [ __ ] beat out of us and it
wasn't any there was nothing like
sexy or even funny or cute about it we
were losers we were the scum of the
earth
so yeah
that you know that gives you a little
backbone you know that gives you a
little
metal
i'm now picturing you
uh dungeons and dragons and uh this this
curious bright person but making that
transition uh into theaters because
those kids i always saw as
they didn't seem as outgoing as
confident i guess as as a lot of those
theater kids were
um
what do you think gave you that you know
how did those two things
co-exist a a desire to make people laugh
and entertain people and also
uh be feeling ostracized and being
treated like a nerd it was a really
interesting time
for me and i remember
what happened very specifically i moved
to a new high school i moved from
suburban seattle
um to this new high school
north of chicago which was
kind of a fancy high school but
called new trier and it's a well-known
high school but
i my parents moved there because they
were working at the baha'i national
center which was very close by in
wilmette illinois
and
we didn't have any money or anything
like that but we're in this all of a
sudden this rich high school and had an
amazing drama department and i had
always just thought about acting i loved
goofing off and just kind of the back of
my mind was like i want to try that
acting thing and
so i took an acting class at this new
high school and
our first assignment was to do this
acting exercise called
uh private in public where
you are just being like in your bedroom
and people are watching you
um and
i put on
a cassette of an elvis costello song
mystery dance and i started just like
goofing around like crazy dancing around
like like i dance around in my room
um and it got raucous laughter and it
was just like this peels of laughter
and then i finished it and then all
these cute girls came up and
i don't mean to be derogatory but
attractive young women came up but you
know
i'm speaking as a 16 year old i'm like
oh my god those cute girls are coming up
yeah to me and they were like oh my god
you're so funny what's your name hi
you know my name's susie my name's treya
do you want to come
sit at our lunch table welcome i'm so
glad you came to our school
and they were you know they touched me
and like i hadn't been like touched by a
girl before and yeah i remember in my
head justin going like [ __ ] the chess
team
like
i'm yes it was like there was no turning
back i was
i was on a track i was on i was like
that's it i'm done with everything else
i'm doing this i'm gonna do this i get
laughter and i get attention from girls
screw everything else i'm in
that's a universal story that's almost
i mean a version of that story exists
even with like
actors that i would have just phil
hoffman said something similar that i
mean not on this part but like
you know really dignified respected
action and i think
it just makes sense i mean that was that
age i mean that's all i sure i thought
about um i remember going from boy
scouts i was so into boy scouts and
badges and like
fishing and turtles and reptiles and all
these and
within maybe a week you know it was like
oh [ __ ] all of that just like you said
about the chess team i had [ __ ] church
similar turn yeah then there was no
looking back at that point i just kept
going and studying and
you know i
um
i i have told this story before but it's
such a memorable story for me at this
high school i really started thinking
like well could i do this i don't know
where i got the ideas like could i do
this professionally um
and i went to my drama teacher
and
on on a break and i said may i speak to
you and i was so nervous i remember
sweating i was pimply really skinny back
then
um
and
i was like
could i do you think mrs adams do you
think that i could ever be
an actor
and she was like oh yes
you must try and be an actor and
you should but you must fall in love and
travel the world and read lots of books
and and
and fall in love and have experiences
and
but
she really
yes she believed in me and she said and
she supported me in doing that and yeah
that was had she said
well i mean you're you know you've got
some talent but god it's so hard
nobody ever really makes it and one out
of a thousand people will try so good
luck
you know i might not have done it but
that's amazing her wholehearted
enthusiasm
uh really inspired me to continue as an
actor well rain you may have told that
story before but i'm glad you told it
again because i think it's really
important for uh i mean for teachers too
to remember the kind of
power that they have you know the
authority i'm glad for as a fan of yours
too i'm glad that mrs m uh to send this
to you are you a fan of mine yeah of
course i love your word yes i'll get to
it i'm gonna that's so sweet i mean not
in everything i lost track of you after
galaxy quest did you continue working
after galaxy quest
[Music]
this segment is brought to you by bud
light seltzer's new retro summer pack
that's a throwback voice whoa dude you
know what i miss being a kid i miss
being in general i miss being a kid but
i miss summers during summer is watching
the mets and inevitably they would fall
apart usually by the end of the summer
because you know the mets are
heartbreakers they would always
yes i always had such great memories
watching those seven o'clock games oh
yeah remember when they got bobby
bonilla and it was like oh my god all
bets are off now and back then if you
were an adult you could sit back have a
drink maybe have a budweiser relax watch
the game i couldn't do that i was a kid
but guess what now i can and now it's
easier with a limited edition bud light
seltzer retro summer pack it's a cool
tie-dye pack which features three
throwback flavors which
reminds me of summer's gone by so it's
blue raspberry summer ice and cherry
limeade i prefer summer ice i think but
i also like the other two a lot they're
all really different you prefer i mean
i'm a cherry limeade guy i also like
blue raspberries i sure do i've talked
about my love of all three flavors now i
forget which one i love the most but i
just know that if someone hands me a
retro flavor a bud light i'm not to
complain i'm not going to say wait which
flavor is this i'm going to pop it open
and enjoy it for the first time ever
fans can also purchase these out of
sight flavors in a new form with bud
light seltzer retro summer icicles which
are extremely refreshing and just as
boozy try some for yourself get it
delivered right to your door find a
retailer near you at bud light.com
delivery or
christian you pick it up yourself at a
local grocery store convenience store or
liquor store hello hello
[Music]
once you were on that track once you set
your mind to that was that just uh did
that just happen naturally you just
applied to a bunch of schools and you
you went whole hog whole bore what
happened was i had great success in
college and i was playing leads in a lot
of plays and i was like oh maybe i can
do this and so i was living in seattle
at the time going to university of
washington
and i decided to start auditioning so i
got headshot and made a little resume
and
just started like pounding the pavement
and going out and trying to find
auditions at local theaters and stuff
and i started auditioning at local
seattle theaters and
i realized like oh
you're you're bad like
i was i was a big fish in a small pond
at the university of washington
but i was not
nowhere near ready for professional work
i just was out there in front of
professional directors and reading with
professional actors that were you know
there to be readers and
and i was just like i just felt i'm out
of my elements here i don't know i don't
i don't have the confidence i don't have
i didn't audition for seattle rep and
they were like listen you've got two
paths to go you can either go to a
training program or you can go to like
ashland at the oregon shakespeare
festival and be an understudy and hold a
spear
for three or four years five or six
years and get your training that way and
that wasn't discouraging to you that
wasn't like oh [ __ ] well maybe time to
pack it in no i was very
i don't know why or how but i was very
driven i think justin um
my dad who i've spoken about and he
passed away this last year he passed
away in july i'm sorry um yeah thanks it
was uh very sad
he was kind of a failed artist
and
he was a very talented painter
and writer but he could never get
anything going but at the same time he
never really pursued it professionally
he would just kind of do it on the side
and he and i would always say to him
even when i was like 12 years old i'd be
like
dad you got to take your paintings down
to the galleries in seattle and
try and hang them and try and get a show
and you've got a network and stuff i was
like 12 or 13 this nerdy kid telling my
dad to network
[Laughter]
and
but he never cared about that so when i
started shifting towards like oh i want
to be an actor i knew what it was like
to be a not successful artist
i knew what that path looked like and it
was not pleasant and it meant you know
working in a sewer construction company
to pay the bills when you really wanted
to be a painter or a writer so i was
like i don't want to do that i need to
get the best training possible i need to
be driven i need to commit to this whole
hog i'm glad you had the experience of
you know watching him go through that i
mean it that it it thickened your skin
it it gave you a drive yeah it it it did
that it was like if i'm going to make it
i know that it's going to be
a lot of work and a lot of rejection and
and also like i need to put my ego aside
and kind of recognize right oh i'm not
very good at this and i need to get
better and i need training and i need
help
were there guys rain that you looked up
to that you saw um careers that you you
would cite as
examples of what you wanted i i could be
like this guy i could be the new
dustin hoffman or whatever
i never really thought about being in
film or tv i mean honestly i was really
a theater
dude and i was thinking like
i wanted to go
back to seattle and be a member of
seattle repertory theater and
play different roles in a shakespeare
play or a farce or you know or a comedy
or something i never really
you know matt ross right
yes yeah
he was at the university of washington
at the same time as me oh no kidding and
also garrett dillahunt was there at the
same time
and uh he's a great actor and um great
actor
lynn shelton the filmmaker oh man yeah
she said she was there
yeah she she passed away uh which was
very sad but we were and my wife we were
all there at the same time but but when
matt ross around the same time moved to
new york city and he had pictures of
like
sean penn up on his wall like he really
was like i want to
be
in in films i want to be a
star in film and tv and i'm not trying
to disparage him at all that that's
that's a great goal why not you know
you're an actor
um
and oddly enough he's actually directing
sean penn in a in a in a mini series
right now and he had sean penn hanging
on his weird really
yeah
i wonder if he wouldn't be embarrassed
that sean penn now knows that he had i
need to somehow get a note to sean penn
that matt ross had a picture of him on
his wall
matt okay well he's yeah so you
mentioned he's directing but he's turned
into he's made
he's become a very successful wonderful
director yeah he's a terrific director
um
captain fantastic was a movie he did a
couple years back with vikko mortensen
it was just fantastic yeah it was
captain fantastic but yeah so i didn't
really i didn't really have i didn't
think of it in those terms i mean a lot
of people
pick someone like dustin hoffman like oh
i could be like that but
i wasn't even thinking about that i just
wanted to be
i wanted to be in a repertory theater
and get 50 000 a year and be able to pay
my rent yeah
so then how do you make that transition
i mean we our first movie your first
movie i didn't know it was your first
was galaxy quest yeah um was that your
first movie it was my first as well yeah
you were great in it
oh
as were you i i uh i also really loved
meeting you there because i
not that we were the same age but you
were closer in age to me than you and
sam
so it felt uh i felt a little
less alone because it was such a new
thing for me i was i had never been to
la i i think i had only flown on a plane
once i mean
everything was so new to me so um
anybody who treated me kindly on that i
i always uh look it's really it's like a
car with wings and it flies look mom
i i love doing it i love doing that
character
how did debbie debbie zane who cast it
uh thank you debbie
how did uh what was that process was it
just a simple audition for you i had
gotten cast in a very small role in
almost famous around the same time oh
and i think right
yeah
and in fact both of those
shot that same summer
you were in the um
that's right you were one of the rolling
sto a writer right yeah yeah exactly
and you had a long cigarette holder
didn't you
yes exactly yeah exactly so i think my
my pretty useless agents did something
not so useless which was to kind of say
hey he just got cashed in this
almost he came out from new york this
kid you know
yeah you gotta see him and in
the role all your reps are old-timey
listen
listen he's gonna be a big big star
so
um
but i mean come on the audition for
galaxy quest was like to be an alien so
i was like i mean what more perfect
casting is there than rayne wilson
playing an alien because i basically
emanate well
was that all did you guys come up with
that stuff that that language that the
um
and the walk and all that was that dean
pariso the director who did that or was
that part of the audition
um
we that was part of the audition
we did we played around with that but
early on
um
i wasn't actually there for that but uh
enrico cole and tony and missy pyle
and
um
[Music]
and uh jed reese were the other aliens
and they came up with the walk and the
some of the sounds and just the world of
being an alien but dean pereso was
really i mean he was such a great guy so
collaborative
and
fun and um
uh he was he was just great so it was a
really fun first job to have
what were your memories of because i i
really loved him and miss him um
what were your memories of of alan like
of alan rickman because you had some
stuff to do with him i know there's a
really touching scene that patrick has
with him
but yeah well i don't i don't have
memories of like working with him but i
do remember
how
incredibly kind he was and
being on a break and
he would just start talking to me he
would just be like well this is turning
into quite a day isn't it
um
enjoying yourself
um and i was like wait
i don't know if he was a is was he a
knight sir was he a sir alan rickman he
might as well ben i don't know he may as
well have been he should have been yeah
he wouldn't have carried the title
around though and i was like this guy
who is talking to me like
that's that's incredible because
you see how rare that is in hollywood
that usually you're working and the
stars
really don't have anything to do with
the day players essentially so yeah yeah
it was it was incredible and sigourney
weaver was the same way she was yeah
incredibly just kind to everyone yeah i
do remember that as well i that i was
thrown by that you know because um
sounds like you we were in the same
similar situation i never been around
famous actors really like actors with
that kind of
status that that stature um
so that was a surprise but i didn't have
as much to do with them i had um
so i ended up hanging out with rockwell
the the most and he was probably the
closest in age uh
i remember running into years later do
you remember this at the movie theater
i think with sam and you had just uh
i asked you how you're doing you know we
were catching up about work stuff and
you said oh i just um
i remember this and i've never told you
this but
you had said i i just did the pilot's
pilot for the office and you were like
sort of you were psyched about it you
were like
yeah i mean it was obviously like a big
thing to get that pilot um
but i remember thinking and you said
yeah it's like kind of like the same
thing as the british office and i love
the british office so much i remember
thinking
oh well i i i don't think that's ever
going to work
did you ever have that thought were you
did you or was it just like oh [ __ ] this
is this is a hit this is going to work
um
yeah well
i was a huge fan of the british office
and i was so thankful to to get an
audition and and
eventually after a very long process get
cast and
it was long
i i didn't have
i guess a lot of people were very
skeptical and i was
i was just one of those people who was
like no this is absolutely going to work
they're going to
take this brilliant germ of an idea on
this british series
and we'll expand it and we need to do 22
episodes a year and go on for eight or
nine years
and it's gonna work it's gonna be great
you know like
i didn't have that kind of
and especially when i met greg daniels
the the show runner for the american
show who was just so
thoughtful and
of good taste and funny and
um
i i just knew it was going to be in good
hands wow well obviously you were right
but but um
i i would think just
the thing for me that would have been a
hurdle and this was something i think
pretty remarkable that that you did that
that the the series did in general you
made this character so different i mean
there were
i guess similar
personality
wise dna to to gareth in in the british
version but um
dwight was it was just so unique was
that was that
conscientious on your part was that
from the time of the auditions were they
looking for that a real departure
uh mackenzie crook who played gareth in
the british office uh was so brilliant
and was really inspiring to me on in so
many levels
but i
essentially
just
stole from him
what
i knew would help the character and then
i just
created the rest on my own and the the
thing i loved about him
uh which is one of the principal things
about dwight that really made him work
that they had come up with in the
british office was
he says the most ridiculous things
with total
total earnestness
yes um without without a hint
of that there's comedy being said and
that's it yeah the way he was able to do
that was
genius just genius that was like a
building block for dwight
i also love the fact that he was so
nerdy in certain certain ways but he
also was like
uh national guard military and yes he's
like
there was kind of this
weird nacho thing going on yes yes so i
knew i wanted we wanted that to be part
of dwight where because you can't put
your finger on it's one of the brilliant
strokes of the character and a testament
to greg daniels is that you can't quite
sum up
what dwight is you know is he a nerd
yeah he's a nerd is he a bully yeah he's
kind of a bully
yeah that what an odd combination and i
know i know
and it's funny it was one i had seen in
life before i they were like aggressive
kind of like hostile nerds like my
roommate in college i i would classify
as but if you're listening
i don't
i doubt he is but if he is you know he
he had that sense of i'm sure he's
changed and evolved but there was a
sense of um
yep i'm right and this almost like
militant um
authoritative
like a bully quality uh
and yet he had all the trappings all the
certainly physical trappings of a nerd
and
um
and but he didn't see himself that way
that i think that maybe that's the
difference he he there was a sense of
power that he had
right that was totally undeserved yeah
yeah yeah um
but
i love that i'd like and yeah how would
you really
how would you describe that in in a
character breakdown or like some sort of
log line it's it's something that
the actor there's got to be like a great
synthesis of writing and acting and and
you you had that i mean that was just a
i was just a brilliant character and i
mackenzie crook had it but it's um
i i i that's why that character never
gets tiring because in life i love those
characters i love those people
yeah it must have been so fun to do
though rain
it really was fun and as the as the
years go by and i've gotten to play a
lot of great roles and great shows and
movies and whatnot but
realizing like and i knew this while we
were doing it but just how special it
was
what we were crafting on the office and
how genius the writing was and how great
the the writers were and the directors
that we got to work with like paul feig
and
um
many others can guap us
rain i love watching the outtakes it's
one of my favorite things to do uh if i
if i'm down at all those outtakes are so
good of both series but um who who was
the and i think i might know but who was
the first to break who would who was the
most guilty of going uh john krasinski
broke all the time
um
[Music]
if if he broke
i would break
almost almost immediately but
um the worst was brian baumgartner who
played kevin i mean he would just break
you could just like raise your eyebrow
and he'd just start to laugh yeah
and oscar was
oscar never broke i think maybe he broke
once in like 200 episodes he never steve
almost never maybe steve broke a handful
of like seven times in yeah in seven
years but
but oscar nunez maybe he broke once
that's incredible they they said that i
remember hearing that about chris
parnell
on snl and if you watch like you can see
it in the cowbell sketch with chris
walken i think he's the only guy not
laughing but they said chris parnell
never
ever broke and to me that's like that's
really impressive because i'm pretty bad
at it
and people always say like how did you
get through that doing the office
without cracking up or with a straight
face how could you say those lines with
a straight face it's like i never i
didn't i didn't just look at the
outtakes i was laughing all the time
come on
[Music]
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
i didn't realize how much work you did
um on behalf of animals
how many animals you have uh yes how did
that start rain how far back um does
that go and
i had read that you became a vegan
because you adopted pigs yes can you
talk about that i have a confession to
make you lied i'm no longer vegan oh
okay and we'll be right back thanks
everyone
i had um no i was i was a vegan i
stopped eating pork we got pigs
okay i'm gonna start at the beginning
i'm not any great animal animal advocate
i mean i love animals and we've always
had rescue dogs we always my wife and i
we've been together a very long time
we've always had two
pitbulls and we always get rescues and
we kind of rehabilitate
kind of really
uh wounded pit bulls that have
socializing problems
and
we have two right now diamond and poe
that we love but we've had lots of pit
bulls over the years my wife rides
horses
um we rescued a donkey
named chili beans we have a donkey
rescue
and
my wife has a zonkey
um
oh that's uh those are real zonkey zebra
and a dog they're they're not real
they're a magical creature in our
imagination
but
oh well she's got quite a fertile image
yeah
um she's fertile in many ways
she yes uh
no we that's not a rescue but she saw a
zonkey it is a real thing it is the
spermatozoa
of a zebra placed inside the womb
of a donkey
and
now who would do that why would you do
that i just
just cause humans
you know just
right
right
but my wife
googled zonkey's and
a a company called zebrasrus.com
came up
in riverside california and
she called them and she's like you guys
sell zonkeys and they're like yes in
fact we have a brand new baby zonkey
and they sent her a picture
and said for 3 500
he'll be delivered in six weeks once
he's nursed from his mom he'll be
delivered to your house oh my god so my
wife was like yes
sign me up
oh my god why did she want as a zombie
so where did that zonkey desire come
from i don't know
i don't know
i don't know and when she says something
like this i mean you sounds like you
really love animals but it's like it's
one thing to
love animals but and then to
all of a sudden
be you know have a zonkey
is there a moment of
honey do you try to talk her out of it
is there
a
dude immediately she is always trying to
get new now she wants alpacas
oh man
she wants she wants miniature donkeys
we so we don't have them all in our
house the horse
yeah dinkies the
the horses and the zonkey and the donkey
are nearby at a little ranch stable
thing but um at our house we do have two
pigs um
amy and mr snortington
and
they're
both vietnamese pot-bellied pigs
and
they're delightful creatures and um
uh
yeah they're they're great and so when i
got them
i was like greatly moved to
uh not eat pig
and i still don't eat pig and
also i really quit eating beef because
uh it's so bad for the climate you know
that yeah
if you want to make one difference in
like climate change like don't eat beef
it is just
you can just google it it's i know it's
huge we had not to brag but we had uh dr
jane goodall on the show which was a
huge thrill obviously and that
she made that point i mean that was her
big appeal and and it's the the more
i read about it the more it's inspiring
to to not to
cut it out entirely i know what but what
is it i'm i'm trying rain um
and and this summer i want to make
greater efforts to do that but what what
are the things that you missed i mean
what was the hardest
when in terms of beef and in terms of
pork i'm curious what are the things you
really then i i then i went full-on
vegan for almost a year about 10 months
i went uh
with no fish dairy
anything and
you know honestly it's just
it was great i felt really good like i i
had a lot of health benefits that i
noticed like i
i slept better i felt like i had more
energy through the day
um
it was very it had a lot of positive
impact but it was also really hard and i
got really lazy and then the last
year year and a half
i just have introduced some fish and
just a little bit of fish a little dairy
and a little yeah chicken
um
sometimes but i try and eat
you know even if it can eat one meal a
day that's a plant-based meal that's a
really good thing to try and do and
that's what i try and do still
so it's just and that's what humanity
really kind of needs to like you can
have the discussion in terms of animal
rights like i don't want to kill animals
i love animals yeah i kill them and i
don't want to farm them etc and that's
that's all fine and i get with that but
for me it's more about like the planet
and it's seven almost eight billion
people on the planet and how is that
gonna work and we just need to really
cut back on our meat consumption it
needs to go way way down so that's how i
try and do it now is this something that
comes up often on
metaphysical milkshake do you talk about
the existence of the planet i mean our
own
temporal existence and how to prolong it
is that i would imagine you're pretty
you're well-versed in that well i don't
know that i'm well-versed but that is
something we talk about a lot um
a lot of a lot of the biggest questions
have to do with humanity on this planet
you know if you're dealing with racism
if you're dealing with like gender roles
if you're examining economic inequality
and certainly
man's relationship to nature all of
these
cycle back in some way shape or form to
just
massive imbalances
that are out there um
human beings one to another and human
beings to the planet
and
the the thing that we keep stumbling
upon and it's it's not any big surprise
but
you know
let's go to climate change for instance
like
climate change on its surface seems
pretty simple stop
polluting you know stop emitting you
know these climate heat trapping gases
like you know co2 and methane
and
that's true and we absolutely need to do
that and that should be our first
priority but it goes so much deeper than
that i mean if as you start to kind of
peel the onion of climate change you see
that it has to do with capitalism and
consumerism
and this kind of and this kind of
capitalistic idea that we want unlimited
financial and economic growth
with very limited resources and it it
can't continue
you know does it ever feel
like you're you're drowning in this like
it's too big a thing it's too daunting i
see people littering i see the way
people being wasteful in life and it is
so uh
demoralizing it feels so
um
just hopeless
how do you sustain or just just
just talking about it sustain that hope
you know that's that's a key question uh
justin and it it is
it's such an important question because
i feel the same thing like even in
reading this
why a book about climate change i'm just
like i get so depressed you know
you just read some of these statistics
about
how much co billions of tons of co2 were
releasing into the
air yeah all the time and
um and it's like what can we do
and
but
you know i just coming i just come back
to the fact that
we have to do something and
we can each individually make a
difference but we can do it with our
vote
we can do it to bring attention to to
corporations
you know we still live in a capitalist
system and companies really listen to
the to their consumers
real change can happen so
it's overwhelming but we we have to do
something you know we
for our
grandchildren's children yeah you know
yeah well i'm glad that you're talking
about i'm glad we're talking about it
because um
the more i i do have these oh [ __ ] the
more sorry
the more of these conversations i do
have the more uh
it's solidified it becomes that you're
right something has to i have to start
um
we can only control ourselves so
it's inspiring to me i mean you've
inspired me to want to take measures
whatever i can
and hopefully people listening are
inspired metaphysical milkshake with
risa aslan is
is out can i do another plug though i
have to plug something else okay yeah
there's another podcast i did and um
it's really cool an audible we just
released a really cool thing uh called
killing hollywood and it's the the
cotton club murder story it's the true
story of
um
the bob evans the great producer of the
godfather in chinatown
and then hooked up with these crazy
drug dealer
types this and um
and to finance the movie the cotton club
oh wow
so i play this character it's a scripted
podcast this character named roy raiden
who was a failed broadway producer
um
he he
met this woman named lainey jacobs who
was a drug dealer from miami but she had
grown up in a trailer park and together
with bob evans they were getting the
financing together for the cotton club
and coppola was going to direct it and
it was just this drug fueled crazy
um
murderous orgy of mayhem in hollywood
and it's uh it's on audible it's really
cool oh that sounds that's a true true
story no one's ever heard it's amazing
oh wow and i love but i'd love to hear
about did somebody play bob evans uh
christian slater does oh i would love to
hear that he had he's got one of my
favorite voices that bob evans voice uh
and christian slayer is one of my
favorite voices that julia lewis is in
it i'm seeing this is so cool uh yes
okay great rain yes on audible hey
they're a sponsor that's cool
i have a i have a lightning round rain
um yeah if you if you don't if you'll
indulge me uh which doesn't include this
question but i'm curious where where did
rain come from
it's those hippie parents who
they're not really hippie but bohemian
off-the-wall parents in the late 60s
and um
my dad's favorite poet was this poet
named rainer maria rilke
um wow of course and
so he wanted to name me rainer but then
we lived right by mount rainier
so they thought that would get confusing
so
then they were looking at rain
like rein
and then and then they settled on rain
but then that was even a little too
hippie-ish so they added an extra n
so that's funny
that's funny and when when kids were
teasing you would they would they ever
use your you know rain rain go away
stuff like that oh yes oh yes
yep sorry oh yes they did
wow okay
i just wanted to just opened a very very
old wound
yeah sorry sorry
this is okay let's redirect in a fun way
because now you're successful and you're
doing great things for the world and um
and
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say
uh poop
yeah sure okay
no that's not true though i thumbs up
it's thumbs up
thumbs up wins the emoji war the thumbs
up is just
i just uh my finger is constantly on the
thumbs up button
yes that's a pretty common one yeah it's
very useful um
i i like emojis that they can they set a
tone but you can you know or
re-establish a tone if
my wife is brilliant at emojis she finds
she unearths
really incredible
emojis from from
in the in the back of the emoji pack the
back catalog
it's almost like the ones that you've
never seen i know i have a friend who
does that like i didn't know they had a
like a tinker bell i didn't know there
was like a mermaid one with a triton
exactly if
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play tennis
oh tennis you have a favorite you have a
player you like
uh i like federer but i'm a fan of all
the all the greats i'm just a fan of the
sport yeah
um but i'm a fat head
in fact
oh yeah of course
uh is that what they call themselves
i don't know i just made that up oh it's
good um if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life
what what would that be
it would be uh
uh tortilla chips
oh any specific brand no you know when
you go to the mexican restaurants and
they have like the really the fresh made
ones that are like kind of oily
yes that are thicker and they're kind of
crispy and like i could just i'm going
to be buried in a in a sea of those
but of course that that would imply that
i couldn't eat them because i'd be dead
but
you get the idea
yeah it'd be a good way to die is to be
no i would like to be placed face down
in a in a vat of those chips and just
start eating until i passed away
what i for some reason now picturing
dwight and the beets and what what is
that something that what is the most
common thing people say to you when they
yell things that i'm sure
you have a very recognizable face uh is
there is there a common thing they talk
about beats they talk about references
to dwight
um yeah you know yo dwight um
uh
what kind of bear is best bears beats
battlestar galactica
uh
you know all the old standbys yeah okay
um what is your favorite uh
uh do you have kids right i have one i
have one kid he's 16. yeah oh wow okay
uh yeah i should have known that um was
there a movie that you were or maybe you
haven't shown them yet but maybe when he
was younger was there a movie that you
were most excited to share with him like
i can't wait to watch this with my kid
yeah you know i did a couple of movies
back in the day about 10 years ago that
are really great for kind of
pre-adolescence yeah one was called one
was called the last
of super yeah no super um
the uh one was called the last mimsy and
it's kind of like this
almost disney-ish kind of science
fiction
y.a
but it's it's really cool and and
if you're
between 8 and 12
or 13 you just love it it's really
magical is that about a dragon rain
no dragon no no okay well then i won't
be watching
yeah um
uh you only watch dragon movies yo
strictly yeah
yes
uh what is what's your go-to karaoke
song if you were to go see i know
krazynski is a big
karaoke guy or he used to be
um
um i've never gone with him
um i my go-to is smells smells like teen
spirit
but i do it do it as sinatra
oh really
come
as you can kill them
get kills
i
know
with the lights down
this if this is dangerous here we are
now entertain us
sounding
stupid and contagious
that's funny here we are now
yeah
yeah and here we and here you are all
now hey
um
what but uh who was your first celebrity
crush
speaking of
sinatra
uh
cheryl ladd
oh yep
was one of the charlie's angels yes
uh if you had to get a tattoo
uh what would you get i don't know if
you have any but if you had to get a new
one what would you get
you know what i thought would be a
really cool tattoo is the submarine from
yellow submarine
oh yeah
in that design in that kind of yeah
rendering but it would be really it
would have to be really colorful and i
know people don't really do colorful
tattoos it's kind of like
it's all about the black and white kind
of inky kind of thing pinky dragons yeah
it'd be hard to have a yellow submarine
without any color
you would need that yeah yeah yeah
we had this question about the beatles
and what what your favorite what song
you would want to hear now uh
what if if you could if you could play
the beatles what what are some that you
really gravitate toward
is it the the second side of abby road
that has that kind of medley like her
majesty
it's a pretty nice girl in the end and
in the end and yeah
um
that whole that whole bunch of sausages
yeah yeah yeah here comes the sun king
they all kind of
blend into each other like i love that
whole section i do too um what a good
call what's your favorite fruit rain
you know what i'm gonna go with the
loquat
huh
that's
i think our second uh that's a that's a
cup that's a type of kumquat a plum
kumquat i don't know if it's related to
the kumquat i'm gonna imagine it is but
i have these loquat trees
in my uh in our house
and uh they're delicious they don't keep
that's why you don't see them in stores
like once you pick them like in a day or
two they would kind of start to go bad
so why would i eat them off the tree
wow no they're like they're orange and
they're about three or four inches and
you peel them and they're kind of a
little sweet and a little tart and
they're just fantastic oh
i'm confusing them with a plut i think
uh which we had a couple weeks ago
that as an answer i think this is our
first low quad how cool
i'm your first loquat that's fantastic
yeah wow okay thanks rain i i had so you
kind of need a tree a loquat tree
you kind of need a loquat tree or if
you're in the neighborhood anyone just
come on by
um i would love that actually i'll be
there at the end of july so
get your number and i got to send you
some stuff too um who's your favorite uh
we used to ask who's your favorite
muppet character we changed it to the
simpsons but i imagine
you were probably more of a muppet guy
that was our generation uh
did you have a favorite muppet
wow that's good favorite muppet
um
i gotta go with animal you know i played
the drums and the rocker and i still
play the drums and
i always loved animal he's kind of a one
joke muppet but it's a good joke dogs
are cats rain dogs
with you i'd have to say like alpacas or
zonkeys
yeah exactly
sorry so are the alpacas gonna happen i
like alpacas
yeah so you wouldn't raise you wouldn't
trim them use their fur for anything i
would make their fur into a pair of sax
underwear
life is short brought to you by saks
underwear
that's it there's no better thanks
rain i i can't thank you enough this has
been so
so interesting i can't wait to listen to
metaphysical metaphysical milkshake if i
can say it uh and all the other ones
that you plugged when you weren't
supposed to
um yeah but perfect we're going to talk
about it on the outro with my brother uh
it's just really nice to see you and
catch up hey it's great seeing you again
and um
i hope our paths cross again and i hope
we get to act together again
and um i i hope so too i'll hopefully
see you soon all right kids thank you so
much for having me this was really fun
justin thank you really okay really fun
thank you rain much love to you all
bye-bye
[Music]
so that happened
that's pretty good well that just
happened yes it's very there's something
um it might
it might be a little bit doing like
wallace sean yeah why am i doing that
yes it's a little um
well it's sort of like this isn't it
isn't it a little bit here well that
happened well that maybe not as deep
well that just happened anyway i i guess
i can't do a rain wilson impression i
think that's what i've just discovered
what if anyone does a rain wilson
impression
he it's the cadence he has a specific
cadence really and he
not not totally unique but he hits words
he's very crisp he's a christmas speech
there's a little bit of a
like vulcan energy yeah yes well maybe
that's why
his first role that's why i say he made
fun of him yeah he's like rayne wilson
playing an alien it's like a no-brainer
yeah yeah and he it's funny because he's
an interesting combination of
when he said he was in dungeons and
dragons in high school was obviously no
surprise because he has
a bit of that and he's certainly got
that
aesthetic you know a kid we wouldn't be
surprised to see him in the dungeons and
dragons but he's also so um there's
something so hip and
uh i now find
i i think of cool in different terms now
i i like define it differently than i
did when i was
in high school i should hope so yeah
quite quite a different also society
defines it differently yeah from when we
were kids that's true like he said he
was a nerd before it was cool to be a
nerd it's now cool to be a nerd to the
point where you guys talk about
people who
definitely weren't nerds back then
refer to themselves as having been a
nerd at a certain time their lives
because it makes them
more impressive sounding well it
reminded me of how you often call me out
for claiming to be a nerd myself when he
was talking about that um i started
thinking about my own high school
experience and it brought me back to
the reality of my experience which was
probably quite different than reigns and
it made me a little sheepish about
claiming
a similar brand of nerdum yeah that he
claims yes you know because i think he
had i think he was much more of a true
nerd than i guess i know he was to some
extent it's all a bit relative
in that
i would say
let's say um
megan fox or i'm trying to think of some
like cool pretty actress you know she's
a nerd
really no no oh no let's just say like
when i see her someone like um what's a
better experience well would you say
that zoe deschanel is a nerd uh-huh
because she's very pretty she's very hip
she's cool yeah i think she could have
been nerd but someone who is like cool
and edgy and seems so confident
someone like that saying they're not i
would say you were probably more of a
nerd than that person right then i would
also say exactly but i would say rain
wilson is was more of nerd than you were
you were like yeah on you were on the
scale of nerd you were on the scale yeah
but you just weren't to this side of the
scale it's true i think like um now
people make like lay claim to that
because it's uh like you said it's cool
now and and i think part of what made it
cool is our our people like rain and and
uh he mentioned steve jobs and there are
certain like nerd touchstones that have
that have made it cool yeah there's
another nerd touchstone oh man uh bill
bill gates i guess i mean someone maybe
we can't name anymore but um oh right
yeah yeah he was a nerd and then
that's like a story i've heard a million
times now on the show where
uh an actor is like oh yeah then i
wanted to hang out with girls so i did
oh my god i did plays oh my god it's
like i wouldn't be surprised if daniel
dan day-lewis if you if you uh talk to
dan day-lewis and he and you got him to
be really i'm sure he'd be honest how
that guy seems like he's incapable of
dishonesty you know it's certainly in
his work do you think he um so i bet he
i wonder if he'd answer at the same time
he's a teenager when you're a teenager
that's
what drive i'm sorry you don't have to
apologize no i know i'm apologizing to
some people who might be a little upset
about that well who would be upset it's
human nature it's biological i was
listening to that and i was thinking god
i wonder if people get upset about
curing rain say that but it's like how
can you it is you're right it's [ __ ]
biological some people will get upset
but some people get upset about anything
i know you can't cater to the most
sensitive people
it would be the most saccharine
[Music]
as it is this is not the edgiest show in
the world i don't know i know but that
can stand to be a little less true
that's true okay well then i stand by my
comment teenagers yeah i like girls oh
my god
too much too much sorry a real
background really alright you're gonna
have to take care of that nope keep it
in reel it back from here on out or
bleep it out okay it might be funny
that's true i don't want to say that
it's just such a effect you were joking
i know
you know he did i will say the one
person he cited
as um someone who claims they were a
nerd but like definitely wasn't back in
the day was brie larson yes and he's
wrong i think she was a nerd i think she
oh my god you don't both have to think
brie larson was an actress you were
buddies
i knew her a bit and um now she people
know her as this you know big marvel
that's right you met her in fact when
she was when she was a nerd yeah she was
quite nerdy
yeah i mean cool and no no yeah yeah no
one had those nerdy quote-unquote nerdy
we should preface every time we say
someone's a nerd i i i like nerds i mean
nerds of course you know so yeah brie
was i i think brie was an american she's
like this bombshell
famous actress but she knows like
scrappy cool
weird nerdy girl yeah she's very
creative she used to sing all the time
she should on the podcast we should hey
bri if you're listening
uh we should i should
that'd be great funny the one example he
cited was i think he's wrong about it
but i can understand why he would say
that i would i can understand why he
might presume she wasn't you know yes
exactly um but no and i think that's why
she's really great on talk shows and
stuff she's very funny and because i
nerds um have to cultivate a sense of
humor i think a lot of nerds are funny i
agree
yeah unless they're so nerdy that they
never learn those social well see that's
what's interesting about the character
he plays that's what i love about dwight
schrute and what mackenzie crook did on
on the british office because that is a
brand of nerd that is unaware of um
how aggressive they are and and uh
how obstinate that they can be yeah and
i i of course we've all known people
like that i never put like a comic book
guy yeah
i never put that together until he said
that um this similar that similarity
between
the british
version of that character the bbc
version of the office and the american
version
um is that but it but he's totally right
that it's like
that character is
so incredibly
earnest oh my god and
and sincere
and like
and completely incapable of seeing
something that's clearly funny yeah i
mean that's why that's why martin
freeman on the british one and krasinski
on the american one they're able to
tease them with some by doing so little
i mean they're able to they can say so
much with a look like that's why cr and
krazynski they both did it so well
martin freeman and john that just looked
uh like a quick glance to the camera did
so much work because
rain and mackenzie on the bridge were
doing such crazy [ __ ] and they would say
like i remember
the the one where uh he he has a holster
he puts his phone in a holster it's a
ridiculous thing and he does it he's so
earnest about it yeah it's my it's for
my phone yeah it's so great the first
time we saw first time i saw the office
i think this the same for you the
american version it was like
no this is not yeah this is not right
because they did line for lion
the same exact version line for line of
the pilot of the british office which
i held so dear and i i had seen so many
times i loved it so much so when i saw
the american version i was like rayne
wilson's character i was like no this
isn't this is
totally wrong i know he's not doing it
right you don't both have to have
written off the american office after
having seen the pilot because he was a
carbon copy of the british one but then
i had to die years later i got into the
american office i started every single
episode and it's brilliant i still have
so many and so is he yeah he's amazing i
know he's and it is different it is
different from that character but it's
more similar in hearing him talk about
it how he stole certain things from it's
more similar than i ever even realized
but i i think that's probably why he had
trouble
uh breaking up because
he you know laughing too much is because
the things he was asked to do were so
ridiculous and to do this with a
straight face requires
um
[Music]
not that he wasn't committed but like it
requires so much commitment so much more
than a than a
quote-unquote normal character because
he's
he's saying like things that most like
99. and so steve carell and he's he that
was interesting when he said that he was
um he was one of the last to break steve
krill it's i've it it's got to be so fun
to do that it seems like he has some
elements of dwight in terms of a little
bit of like they're both very eccentric
and analytical like that yeah yeah like
his childhood is his own father
is
to talk about eccentricity oh my god
moving to the middle i know nicaragua
and starting the classical music radio
station and being an oyster farmer yeah
i know what a wild i know what a wild
childhood experience yeah it's like what
you what dwight schrute's father may
have been like yeah and that he's that
he comes from that eclectic of an
upbringing it's it's funny that's i
don't even know what the word for that
is it's like when he was talking about
those worms coming out of his butt
i saw marshmallows today now you said
they're as white as marshmallows it made
me think i might never be able to have a
marshmallow me too you don't both have
to be scarred from eating marshmallows
because of rain wilson's worm story
i thought the same
thing i might i still saw him today i
was at
uh not a sponsor whole foods and i saw
you know a bunch of marshmallows in line
and that's the first thing i thought of
and i think maybe
because that story how do you that story
is indelible oh like it's impossible not
to picture it
and he said it so casually it's awful
and the way he said i forget what other
adjectives used uh to describe what the
one smooth but he said they were a
little john hodgmany a little bit yes i
wonder if they were
yes
i also love the idea of his podcast it
sounds like i know fantastic
metaphysical milkshake i know it's
almost like he came up with the name
first because it sounded so funny yeah
and he was like what should we what's
your way
what should we do about the metaphysical
milkshake what does that conjure well
exploring the questions of life and uh
yeah i know he's just a really
thoughtful person a real fertile brain
in there yes in that noggin in that big
noggin yes and uh inspiring to eat less
meat
yeah i know i know beef specifically i
know and i liked his honesty about his
own
struggles but um how he's taken a step
back and you know i i like the idea of
um
of of just setting certain goals you
know when it comes to things like that
baby steps baby steps yeah
for example like you said um
do it have at least one meal a day
that's totally meat-free
i know that sounds easy i know but when
you're used to eating meat that's kind
of hard i know you're just sort of
programmed
for meat to be a part of the meal um i
thought he was going to say he was
turned off poor after the bohr story
yeah the bullet yeah
i thought he was gonna say after having
pet pigs
well yeah which he was he yeah but then
he got back into it
yeah
pig is uh i know but they are really
adorable i was i was at a farm recently
in arkansas and i got to meet some pigs
they were for sale and a friend and i
went to go see them and they were i mean
they're really cute they're really cute
and apparently very
very intelligent very intelligent have
you ever heard of a loquat
yes yes i hadn't heard of it oh yeah in
fact i'd seen it somewhere i thought
maybe i've seen it at whole foods but
but then he said they rarely sell them
because of the shelf life yeah um yeah
yeah uh no but now kumquats i used to
like yeah i've seen those people love
kumquats i know you both have to love
kumquats i know kumquats are great and i
i like the idea of um i always used to
imagine that i was a giant yeah just oh
my god yeah me too okay well we had the
same parents we did
we grew up around each other um
let's read a letter yes good this is a
letter
from piet
byers
piet
p-i-e-t
i'm gonna go with pete okay um
pierre i'm sorry if i'm mispronouncing
your name uh
the subject is love from south africa
dear justin and christian south africa
south africa cool my name is piet piet
oh now when she says they say it again
p-i-e-t-i-e piety p-t maybe it is
interesting you assume it's a female ah
pt buyers i absolutely love you guys
pizza to be able to feel cl so close to
people you've never met that is bizarre
it also sounds a bit more australian i
know how do you what's what's the
difference difference it's sort of like
this this at the end i don't know don't
they go like this it sounds quite a bit
trying to think it's australian to me i
know it is a bit awesome oh district
nine what a great movie what a great
movie uh okay i'm not even going to try
it just do your own all right sorry um
so from back to prt
bizarre to be able to feel so close to
people you've never met
and then an old-fashioned full smiley
face with a nose even whoa a winky face
sorry
i've
i've listened to hundreds of podcasts
and you two radiate unparalleled warmth
what a
nice i mean i think our warmth is
definitely paralleled but that's what a
wonderful compliment well not unless you
listen to just like murder podcasts
um you know all about like the black
dahlia that's like a such an amazing
company i know that is really nice
kind of the least i could do is get
their their name right
and gender who cares but gender as well
as the concert
why are you laughing i
don't know
thanks for adding back to piety thanks
for adding soul to our days
i have an afrikaans
a south african language podcast cool
that's not the name of it that was me
editorializing how i felt about that
it's called so loop my
sorry it's called solup haimar
so loop
s-s-o and then l-o-o-p then h-y and then
m-a-a-r so loop hymar where we unpack
the mysteries of life and sometimes just
shoot the breeze sounds like rain's
podcast it also sounds a bit like our
podcast yeah yeah mysteries of life sort
of
sounds kind of more more heavy but now
mysteries cool
no that's ours yeah uh back to piety
this made me think of an appropriate how
about just pete for the rest okay
because because you butchered it a lot
the first half and now i'm knocking the
second half of the letter just go with
pete i'm yeah okay okay or pd
pd i'm gonna go with petey okay this
made me think of it appropriate would
you rather
uh would you rather know what happens
after death or
or rather be the only person to own a
harmless little dinosaur
hmm wow that is a great
question and a couple little follow-ups
um how little is this harmless little
dinosaur number one it's got to be
harmless it's got to be
like no i know it's harmless but how
little is that i don't know right in
terms of like because because saying a
little a little tyrannosaurus rex could
still be really big you would need to
keep it in a yard i guess let's say it's
the size of a deer and then you'd have
to deal with like animal control oh you
have a lot to deal with that's true or
what if it's like the size of a gerbil
okay how about this a harmless dinosaur
could be a like a brontosaur they were
veg they were plant eaters speaking of
rain they were like brontosaurus was a
plant i don't love the look of a
brontosaurus i don't know either any
little head you know both have to not
like the brontosauruses aesthetically
i like stegosaurus oh you do yes little
heads too and they've big plates
triceratops they got a big plate on
their head too
what does stegosaurus have they have big
plates on their backs maybe i'm thinking
of triceratops yeah sorry yeah they have
the three horns yeah yeah yeah
because i was a bit of a nerd let's go
the tyrannosaurus rex a small version of
that what that one
yeah
what about something like jurassic like
a velociraptor
harmless i'm saying use your imagination
that's a harmless version of it
you have to feel like dwight schrute you
have to use your message
it's got to be harmless and small and
non-existent yeah yeah okay so you get
to have a dinosaur see i wouldn't want
the pressure of like having one and i'd
also be kind of sad to have just one
dinosaur and then everyone you know
people want to see it obviously i'd feel
i wouldn't want to withhold it from
that's true then probably uh that would
be the last one not a responsibility
horrible to end the species you'd have
to take care of it with your life i mean
right that's true uh i don't know if i
could handle that responsibility
although i would like to have a child at
some point so maybe i
i should get used to it settle for a
dinosaur i guess um
i'm just trying to imagine the species
of dinosaur that i most want the
harmless little
what um
that's not really the question i know
let's let's
um
let's just say that it's your favorite
dinosaur species okay and it's harmless
and it's small as small as you want it's
not a little pterodactyl it's the size
of a puppy okay okay
i would rather know what happens after
death what if you find out that it's
like a horrible horrible i would
horrible afterlife i would adjust my
life accordingly
i if if you just go balls out oh if
there were a judeo-christian like hell
and heaven and all that what's a judo
christian hell like the construct of
hell like like fire and brimstone yeah
yeah okay i guess that's not true what
is that that's christian right like
evangelical i don't know
i think eventually we're out of our
depth and we are but let's say uh well
let's say you find out that there's fire
in brimstone
that that exists if you if you don't
follow the rules of let's say even if
you do follow the rules
and you know that's coming to you but it
would encourage you to be very pious
no it wouldn't i think in this
hypothetical it's this is what happens
to you regardless you go to hell
whatever this thing is this i'm saying
if you find out yeah that i'm making an
argument for the little dinosaur right
now
because if you find out that whatever
happens to you and you die is horrible
yeah then
i wouldn't want to know that
i would want to just enjoy my life as
much as i could and enjoy my little
dinosaur friend
okay counterpoint wouldn't it help you
wouldn't it make you enjoy your life
more if you knew that it was horrible
that that after life was horrible i
don't think so because then i would be
plagued by the knowledge of what was
going to happen what if you found out
concretely that there was nothing
that's different that's not horrible to
me
that's i mean it's unsettling
but it's not horrible yeah but would it
encourage you to live any differently if
i found out for sure there's just
nothing yeah
uh probably yeah i would probably take
more chances oh yeah i mean
not like life-defying death-defying
chances yeah i would probably try to
have more fun
knowing that there definitely won't be
fun after this what's the first thing
you would do oh so like
fun pleasures of the
like worldly pleasures yeah i would
probably um
strip off my clothes and sprint uh down
the post road pleasure
no it would be taking a chance uh
so you'd rather the little dinosaur
if i found out that the afterlife was
miserable yeah i guess you can't choose
what it is i know that but that's the
choice i mean that's that's uh rolling
the dice i but i would still i think i
would roll the dice and
and hope that it was uh good news
and take that because i'd have it too i
mean i don't really what truth be told
you i don't know i don't want a little
dinosaur are you kidding yeah even if
it's like harmless i'd rather just find
out now i think i'd be really upset if i
found out the news was bad though i know
but then i'd be wishing for that
dinosaur no no then you'd have time to
adjust i mean it would be
like with any
any bad news with any tragic news or any
kind of like pain or loss you just
you're able you probably maybe maybe but
using a very dwight schrute hypothetical
it does it was a great hypothetical
thank you petey
well pt with an ie at the end and then
she says
love you guys
best heart emoji
p-i-e-t-i-e buyers pt buyers
we could be way off could be like payta
pt pt afrikaans afrikaans that's a cool
accent that's a cool act i can't do it
well thank you for that letter if you
had a wonderful compliment and that
wonderful um would you rather she also
says thanks for adding soul to our days
soul what a nice that's also a nice
beautiful
uh if you had to guess would you say pt
is uh
i my instinct was um
that uh pt is a man or identifies as a
man you know i like i actually like that
they didn't include what type of gen
what gender they were because they know
that we we're curious about this is a
very common occurrence on life issues
are you struggling with the gender of
the
well writers well it's also appropriate
for our
guest today rain is a very
gender-neutral name yes there's a reign
phoenix
that's right rubber phoenix is yeah yeah
also a really good actress um
anyway
speaking of anyhoo thank you uh pt or
pete or however you might say your name
you um wrote a beautiful letter and if
you guys would like to write in
we love hearing from you and our email
address is life is short at wondery.com
and we want to thank all of you who've
made it this far
what a slog yeah and thanks to rayne
wilson and go listen to his podcast yes
it is called metaphysical milkshake say
that sometimes metaphysical milkshake
metaphysical milkshake metaphysical
milkshake your eyes are all over the
moment
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long another producer on this
is megan v monaco senior producer is
michelle miesch lans audio engineer i
just saw him hi again sergio enriquez
executive producer who i've not seen in
a while is marshall louie for a company
that is doing great doing great
wondering bye
[Music]
because he acted like an adult that's
what made him nerdy as a kid but i
wouldn't
necessarily call that nerd he was a nerd
yet because he was still yeah yeah
it's weird i'm thinking like a young he
became
a teenager you know what it is a big
part of puberty puberty he really makes
it where you become suffer like yeah
self-aware if you become suffering
awkward
they call it an awkward phase for a
reason because things grow in weird ways
and it's where it's like a metamorphosis
and that's you're being judged by the
opposite sex that's when
he judges his sexual being
and if you fail that test if you're too
awkward
then you become a nerd that's true
that's true nerds and that's why nerds
when you're a kid nurse fail puberty
also when you're a kid and you don't
have you can be you can be a nerd if you
don't have the right clothes or if you
don't have the right glue that's true
that's true there's a bad loop yeah but
that shouldn't that's now we know that
that's not what makes a mirror in fact
cool people i think people figure that
out and like now cool people are
celebrated for not having
the proper luke
that's true see if this makes sense uh
nerds fail puberty
you